this is a biology lesson outside the
classroom school girls from loreto
college are on a field trip to the ELO
secret Egret island most of what grows
and lives here is unique to Mauritius
but the great white egrets are long gone
the Mauritius Wildlife Foundation
maintains a dozen nature reserves
throughout the country d on la bouche Fe
is an eco Ranger for the NGO today she's
guiding the girls on a nature trail the
theme of of our tool here it's exactly
let us go back in time and that's my
role for learning with nature it's more
to help merchant people local to know
more about the endemic species so this
is where people will definitely find
both endemic plants and animals
completely free more than 60 species
most of them endemic like this rare
olive white I are at home here the girls
get worksheets and exercises and they
regularly encounter animals that have
resettled in their former habitats
mauritian society is gradually gaining
awareness the learning with nature
program is consistently acquiring more
converts this is the reason most of the
primeval forests have disappeared from
Mauritius sugarcane plantations together
with the textile trade they sustain the
country's economy after nearly 500 years
of settlement the country now has only
five percent of its original forests
Vance all flow all says it's impossible
to turn back the clock preserving what's
left is hard enough biologists like him
find the Highland forest here the best
place to do their research this cleared
area is in private hands forrest was
really well preserved in the first place
but then very importantly the invasive
alien plants have been removed as you
can see just behind
here dying tree there this is an
invasive plant and you can see it's been
ringing bart at the base and if you look
over there you will see that this area
is very dense because it's still full of
invasive alien plants they have not yet
been removed when you remove them you
have a much more lighted place that we
are in here and as you look around you
here you see a lot of young plants
growing the forest start generating
again the scientists register every
discovery and later analyze it in the
lab they're cataloging the unique
biodiversity of Mauritius it will take
years before this forest area is
completely freed of invasive plants time
and again they have to cut down on
endemic species like this cinnamon tree
and the giant bats known as flying foxes
are returning the only mammals
indigenous to the country they're
especially fond of eating the ripe
fruits of the ebony tree which is again
growing here in increased numbers they
are more important now than they were
before in the sense that they replace
the rule of the two other species are
going extinct beyond their own role
which is disseminating seeds of many
trees particle either very large species
of trees in the forest invasive
crab-eating macaques have been removed
from these forests they were destroying
endemic plants and the broods of rare
birds
this is where they used to be taken and
kept in cages Marianne and Owen
Griffiths have made a business of
breeding the macaques known in
laboratories as sino mullis monkeys and
selling them for animal experimentation
abroad the proceeds go to biodiversity
protection our challenge is to help with
government with other NGOs protect the
remaining bits of land in one way of
doing it as you've just alluded to is by
up threaten areas and then put in a
conservation program which means
removing the invasive alien species and
helping restore the original forests the
company's macaques are used in research
on Alzheimer's disease and on developing
treatments for multiple sclerosis the
company also has a zoo there's a rare
giant tortoise nursery here as adults
they're released into the wild the
Griffiths own more than 300 hectares of
forest which they're clearing of
invasive species versus is number one in
terms of saving endangered bird species
we've had five species of critically
endangered bird that have been
downgraded from critically endangered to
endanger that's an improvement but is it
right to sacrifice one animal to
preserve many other species on the
internet and social media opposition to
the trade in monkeys from Mauritius is
growing animal protectionists in Germany
have joined the protest in 2013 hundreds
of laboratory macaques from Mauritius
were imported to the country well I did
not get as well the odds this isn't
about individual species it's about the
suffering of individual animals these
animals suffer terribly especially once
they're in the lab when they're
subjected to toxicity tests and when
they tortured to death there's no way
any benefit to other species can
counterbalance that Karina gericke
considers the macaques that were
introduced to Mauritius a part of the
country's history and says there's no
need to catch them or breed them for
experimentation so many mentally
disabled to us if we use human cell
cultures there's no problem transferring
results because it's the same species
we can work with microchips and of
course a lot can be tested directly on
humans without harming them dimensions
of Chardon at the University of
Mauritius van saun Florence knows
opinions are divided on the griffiths
model of species protection but he says
that without access to the forests the
research wouldn't be so productive
licious is a bit of a a precursor of
what the world is going to go through
because of the extent habitat
degradation here a lot of extinction we
are ahead of the world in many ways of
studying conservation in Mauritius gives
us a bit of a advance notice of what's
going to happen around the world the
flying foxes of Mauritius are returning
to the primeval forests they can find
food there now and they don't risk
getting shot in the farmers orchards
you